in this video I'm going to talk about
mode of action of beta-2 agonists so
beta-2 agonists are actually
bronchodilators good bronchodilators so
these beta-2 agonist could be actually
used in the treatment of asthma or other
reversible pulmonary diseases so one
good example of this be two agonists are
albuterol it's a prototype ik beta-2
agonist and in this video I'm going to
describe how this beta-2 agonist
imparts its effect that means how bitter
to agonist helps in bronchodilation so
bronchodilation means are the relaxation
of the smooth muscles of the bronchioles
so how beta-2 agonist performs those and
what are the exact signaling mechanism
beneath this so here for instance that
is assumed this dot represent of beta-2
agonist such as Alberto Ron so this bill
- agonist bind to its receptor that is a
beta 2 receptor on the lung beta 2
receptor is found on lungs so these beta
2 receptor is our seven transmembrane
domain protein it's a g-protein coupled
receptor also so when ligand that is the
beta-2 agonist bind to this g-protein
coupled receptor are the membrane bound
g-protein undergoes a conformational
change and the GDP with the alpha
subunit is getting hydrolyzed and
exchanged with a gtp now the Alpha
subunit bound with the gtp is active and
this activated alpha subunit goes and it
activates adenylate cyclase as we have
seen in the basic mechanism of basic
outline mechanism of any g-protein
signaling cascade and then the second
messenger cyclic AMP II would be
generated from ATP and so on so for the
basic mechanism is the same so what is
the physiological effect of this
mechanism so these fish are these whole
signaling pathway will impart to
physiological effect one is it
tivitz the myosin light-chain kinase
this marched in light-chain kinase is
actually important for muscle
contraction so if these myosin
light-chain kinase or ml ck is
inactivated then the muscle contraction
could be prevented and decrease in
intracellular calcium and in a moment we
will see how these two effects are
actually regulated so in normal cases
calcium would form a complex with
calmodulin and calmodulin will activate
this ml c K that is the myosin
light-chain kinase and the myosin
light-chain kinase will phosphorylate
the myosin light-chain when myosin
light-chain is phosphorylated
it can form cross which with acting and
the result would be muscle contraction
now what happens the as a result of
beta-2 agonist binding to the receptor
it imports a signal which tells the cell
to inactivate the myosin light-chain
kinase so once the myosin light-chain
kinase is inactivated what happens this
phosphorylated the myosin light-chain is
not formed and these cross bridges are
not from so muscle contraction cannot
take place so thus beta-2 agonist
mediated signaling preventing the muscle
contraction and ultimately it imparts
the effect of bronchodilation it also
decreases the calcium 2 plus level and
indirectly are inhibiting the muscle
contraction in this way beta-2 agonist
such as albuterol imparts its effect are
by causing bronchodilation hope you
liked this video and you have enjoyed
thanks light please and please subscribe